the app is a non-stop faucet of unstable  creeps like an nyc subway but with a  direct line into your kid's room next  stop brainwash boulevard take a look  man y'all thought me teaching the  children of  me being paulie was crazy but  not only that but they also know that  i'm gender fluid when babies are born  the doctor looks at them and they make a  guess about whether the baby is a boy or  a girl based on what they look like and  most of the time that guess is 100  correct there are no issues whatsoever  um  and but sometimes the doctor is wrong i  teach my elementary school students  about gender identity some people are  girls some are boys some are both some  are neither uh why do they all have  crazy eyes  i should tell you something hey sean  hannity here hey click here to subscribe  to fox news youtube page and catch our  hottest interviews and most compelling  analysis you will not get it anywhere  else